The character of Ernest Burkhart, I found
absolutely fascinating.
Ernest comes to Oklahoma
and ultimately falls in love with Mollie Kyle.
Sho-mee-kah-see.
I don’t know what you said
but it must have been Indian for handsome devil.
[LAUGHS]
William K. Hale uses that as an opportunity
to prey upon her wealth.
The Osage, they gonna go!
Their time is over.
Ernest is under a very strong influence of his uncle.
He finds himself getting deeper into
murderous plans.
I’m sorry, for all the troubles.
Working with Leo and watching this master
create this character,
it’s unbelievable.
Ernest’s the real life representation
of the incredible greed of that time.
I just love money!
I love it as much as I love my wife.
[LAUGHS]